sí
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el
continente africano sigue su camino
hacia la estabilización de sus naciones
aunque este camino sea difícil tortuoso
y con muchos contratiempos la
inestabilidad política es precisamente
uno de los factores recurrentes que
entorpecen ese tránsito siete golpes de
estado han tenido lugar en el continente
africano en los últimos 18 meses son
hechos que ponen marcha atrás la
construcción o también la consolidación
podemos decir de la democracia el
primero de ellos fue en mali en agosto
del 2020 el ejército tomó el poder
después de unas polémicas elecciones
parlamentarias mal y es un caso
particular porque en sólo nueve meses
hubo dos golpes de estado en marzo del
2021 hubo también un intento de golpe en
níger un intento fallido un mes después
en abril del 2021 en chad el presidente
que llevaba en el poder casi 30 años
murió y se produjo un inusual golpe de
estado poco tiempo después en septiembre
del mismo año un oficial de alto rango
derrocó al mandatario y guinea pasó
también a hacer otra de las naciones en
esta lista pero en octubre los militares
de sudán también incumplieron un acuerdo
de balance de poderes de un gobierno de
transición para enrutar el país hacia
unas elecciones libres las primeras en
décadas y por supuesto pues
protagonizaron un golpe de estado en las
primeras semanas del 2022 una junta
militar tomó el poder en burkina faso y
recientemente un intento fallido de
golpe de estado tuvo lugar en guinea
bisseau ex colonia portuguesa en áfrica
occidental
qué condiciones particulares y qué
condiciones en común reúnen estos países
mencionados que llevaron a estas tomas
de poder inesperadas hay otros países en
el continente que también estén al borde
de caer en esta misma situación estén en
riesgos similares cómo afecta a esto en
términos políticos a la región al
continente africano ya esa región de
áfrica occidental también en particular
que dice la comunidad internacional qué
repercusiones habrá que dicen los
habitantes los ciudadanos de todos estos
países hoy en el debate de france 24
analizamos la situación política y esos
7 golpes de estado en 18 meses que
preocupan tanto a áfrica y a la
comunidad internacional para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a nicole don
gala ella es analista y directora
general de la asociación karibú ella es
congoleña pero se encuentra en la ciudad
de madrid también allí en la capital
española está con nosotros justo bolekia
boleká
él es el profesor catedrático de la
universidad de salamanca también es
escritor académico y correspondiente de
la real academia española también es
congoleño ustedes también nuestros
televidentes pueden participar en el
debate con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 bajo ese arroba
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
también pueden dejar allí comentarios
déjenme todas estas preguntas y
comentarios que tengan con el numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios en torno a este tema y
quiero comenzar entonces con nicole en
la ciudad de madrid que fue la primera
invitada que les presente en esta
introducción del programa nicole gracias
por estar con nosotros en el programa
bienvenida y comencemos hablando de
líneas generales que podamos encontrar
entre estos diferentes golpes de estado
hay algo en común en todas estas
naciones o cada uno tiene un estilo
diferente tiene unas causas y
consecuencias diferentes
muchas gracias por la invitación
que áfrica es un continente de los siete
países que ha tenido un golpe de estado
en esos 18 meses son países diferentes
con situaciones también diferente yo
creo que las causas que ha provocado es
en esos golpes estados también son
diferentes pero hay muchas cosas en
común de muchos de los países ya han
tenido golpe de estado la mayoría ha
sido colonizado por la última entonces
ahí también es un problema muy clave que
hay que destacar en esa situación de los
7 países que han tenido golpes
el estado muchos ácidos colonizados por
francia muchos de esos países también
tienen recursos minerales muy
importantes como podemos ver el petróleo
o algodón
diamante muchas cosas hay que esos siete
países tienen eso porque son también que
es una de las causas principales de todo
eso es golpe de estado porque está ahí
bien es común es que la gente está están
intentando pelear y la comunidad de
internacional también está dentro de esa
liga muchos recursos importantes para la
comunidad internacional en cuanto a las
ex colonias francesas estamos hablando
de mali burkina faso guinea níger y chad
guinea bisseau como lo decía en la
introducción no fue colonia portuguesa
mientras que sudán fue parte del imperio
británico en diferentes momentos de su
historia pasó a saludar ahora ajustó
también allí en la ciudad de madrid
gracias por acompañarnos justo y quiero
conocer sus impresiones sobre las causas
de estos golpes de estado hay algo en
común algunos analistas cuando ocurrió
el primer golpe de estado en mali en el
2020 mencionaron que si no se tomaban
medidas esto podía generar un efecto de
bola de nieve en países vecinos estaban
hablando justamente de burkina faso que
hace un par de semanas justamente una
junta militar tomó el poder allí y sacó
del poder a un presidente que fue
democráticamente electo hay algo allí en
común en estos países o son simplemente
circunstancias políticas diferentes
saludos saludos cordiales
caballeros saludos cordiales y
televidentes
estamos volviendo atrás es decir estamos
volviendo a la época de los hombres
fuertes en áfrica
vamos a leer en los años 60 en un
digamos elecciones libres y muchos
países africanos accedieron la
independencia pero después de unos años
pues empezaron a aparecer los hombres
fuertes necesarios e impuestos por las
ex ex digamos experiencias colonizadores
quiero esto quiero esto decir que
los nuevos golpes de estado indican que
los dirigentes políticos africanos no
hacen correctamente sus papeles es decir
olvidan digamos atender las necesidades
básicas de la población y eso convierte
digamos a las sociedades africanas en
una especie de
en sociedades deseosas de encontrar a
esa persona político que de trate que
intente que les lleve a resolver sus
problemas digamos acuciantes de día a
día trabajo hambre sanidad etcétera si
los políticos de los civiles no han
podido digamos resolver esos problemas
más no han podido colmar las carencias
de las poblaciones evidentemente
aparecen los hombres fuertes promovidos
alentados por las potencias ex colonias
es colonizadoras y se hacen con el poder
con la esperanza de que de la onic de
que puedan digamos hacer lo posible para
que esas poblaciones ya deseosas de
levantarse y de echarse a la calle pues
puedan calmarse durante un tiempo se use
con eso quiero decir que ya mes en
francia el corte del palacio para los
cinco países ex colonizados por francia
llámese portugal es entera llámese
inglaterra están intentando pues de
lanzar un mensaje a la población tiene
señores
pero procuren no levantarse porque desde
otra manera con estos militares que
están ya haciéndose con el poder ustedes
lo tendrán mucho más difícil que en la
época en la que los políticos eran
digamos civiles que intentaban gestionar
la cosa pública su cosa pública por eso
ven ustedes ahora que los plantar es
cuando dan un golpe de estado reciben el
apoyo de la población porque la
población está desesperada esperaba la
población que los civiles haría
imposible para que la sociedad estuviese
bien y han visto que en en en años de
gobierno de exigir a civil la población
sigue con sus carencias sigue con sus
problemas mientras que pp contempla como
mientras contemplan como digamos los
gobernantes se enriquecen tanto en el
país como fuera del país si justo eso lo
vamos a analizar más adelante ese apoyo
que hay a los militares porque por
ejemplo hay casos donde no es así
hablábamos del caso de una de estas
naciones donde los militares
estaban llevando el poder en un gobierno
de transición y al hacer un golpe de
estado precisamente fueron los
ciudadanos los que salieron a la calle a
rechazar este tipo de acciones a pedir
la restitución del gobierno transitorio
y a pedir las elecciones entonces ya lo
vamos a analizar a ver estos países son
tienen unas realidades que son muy muy
alejadas para américa latina son países
de los que pocos se conocen algunos de
ellos son estados muy nuevos son estados
muy jóvenes
que algunos de ellos son tardíos de ese
proceso de descolonización de áfrica
nicole en qué condiciones están estos
países por lo menos los del sahel son
países que están expuestos a la
inseguridad de los grupos yihadistas ahí
ya ustedes lo mencionaban hay mala
gobernanza por parte de los de los
mandatarios instituciones que no son muy
sólidas y tal vez una presión de las
potencias de ejercer y establecer un
modelo democrático que no tiene buenas
bases como son las condiciones en estos
países
las condiciones sobre todo para la
población es de precariedad total y todo
eso es la falta de seguridad para esas
personas la población
no se respeta los derechos humanos yo
creo que en el occidente no deja a
áfrica respirar es verdad que no los
muchos de los mandatarios africanos son
corruptos pero también a demanda carlos
inteligente que pueden gobernar sus
países de una manera digna pero por
desgracia como ha sido países
colonizados yo creo que es una
colonización que nunca se está acabando
entonces y en su vez es la población
ahí mismo ahora en los países que están
pasando esos golpes a dos lleva sobre
todo a la juventud a poder replicar
ciertas cosas intentar marcharse ahí lo
que pasa con la inmigración irregular y
segura porque todas esas personas que
están viviendo esas guerras hoy mismo el
día de mañana buscará otra forma de
poder abandonar el país porque país
entraría en una crisis económica y
social y habrá pobreza hambruna y todas
esas personas buscarán día de poder
salir y habrá también gente que buscar
agosto para poder decir basta ya aquí
hemos llegado como no hay libertad de
expresión esas personas tiene protección
internacional los dirigentes africanos
la de la población es la más tocada es
la que más sufre en todas esas
condiciones la precariedad es la
inseguridad también y la falta de los
derechos humanos justo estamos entonces
ante una posible y ya a unos cuantos
meses de que comience el verano en el
hemisferio boreal que comiencen salidas
de más cantidad de personas de estos
países africanos hacia el norte del
continente en su intento por cruzar el
mediterráneo y llegar a europa por estas
condiciones y que mencionan nicole no
hay libertad de expresión no hay
oportunidades para los jóvenes los
sistemas de salud y de educación son
precarios son gobiernos corruptos hay
narcotráfico amenaza yihadista
prácticamente la población allí no tiene
oportunidades y por eso busca en estos
gobiernos
y son momentáneos que derrocan a otros
gobiernos simplemente como un respiro
esperando que la situación cambie pero
no es así
cierto cierto no es así
evidentemente la gente busca la manera
de respirar un poco siempre que hay un
golpe militar no y aunque sea un golpe
civil que pocos casos se han dado
lo que ha dicho ni con la corrupción
precariedad de hacer falta de derechos
humanos violencia permanente contra la
población civil indefensa todo eso hace
que la población se sienta desamparada
se sienta abandonada por sus propios
dirigentes y eso hace que la población
aproveche cualquier oportunidad que sea
que les brindan para salir evidentemente
todos no son los que pueden salir pero
también hay que tener en cuenta digamos
la la la la inoculación del virus
occidental en la mente de los africanos
es decir no sola no porque haya golpe de
estado no sobre que nos van a salir no
antes incluso cuando no hay golpe de
estado los africanos se van porque se
van porque por falta o por falta de
oportunidad los jóvenes que están
formados solos jóvenes que no están
formados buscan la manera de salir del
país porque no tienen oportunidades en
el país ni siquiera pueden satisfacer
sus propias necesidades de digamos tener
algo que comer y tener donde dormir si
no lo tienen no se obtienen que salir y
dígame usted menciona esta inoculación
del modelo occidental de la comunidad
internacional en los países
colonizadores han impuesto un modelo
pero tal parece que este modelo no da
resultados que es lo que está fallando o
africano es un continente en donde este
modelo occidental este modelo
estadounidense o europeo pueda ser
aplicado por las condiciones que tiene
porque son países que fueron armados por
los países occidentales no son países
con unas tradiciones o historias
que una no reúnan diferentes comunidades
o etnias como las han
puesto en una sola nación en algunos
países siendo etnias completamente
distintas o enfrentadas y las pusieron
juntas en el mismo país entonces me
preguntaba hacia si este modelo
occidental de democracia es
verdaderamente aplicable para el caso
africano
tú lo has dicho usted lo ha dicho es
decir estamos hablando de países
totalmente pluriétnico sí
multiculturales de un tono de vista
ético evidentemente entonces el
occidente ha impuesto un modelo que no
tiene nada que ver con las
idiosincrasias africanas no tiene
absolutamente nada que ver entonces el
africano está viviendo de prestado
es decir el africano todavía no es
soberano ni económicamente ni
lingüísticamente ni culturalmente ni
políticamente ni militarmente el
africano no es soberano está viviendo
según el modelo que venda el impuesto y
eso hace que el africano no se sienta
representado con ese modelo máxime
cuando los dirigentes africanos que
están gobernando el país también son los
primeros primeras víctimas de este de
esta alienación de alguna manera
cultural política lingüística etcétera
evidentemente si usted lo mira no lo
mira desde él desde la cercanía o desde
desde la lejanía se dará cuenta de que
muchos de los africanos que salen de
áfrica salen con lenguas lenguas
occidentales francés inglés español el
portugués etcétera pero nunca nunca el
africano que habla su propia lengua no
tiene la oportunidad de salir porque ni
siquiera tiene la oportunidad de
digamos valerse en él en su propio país
por crear porque le han de ampliar
privado de ser africano
entonces los los que dan golpes de
estado llámese militares los que
gobiernan llámense civiles no no se
preocupan por recuperar las
idiosincrasias africanas a partir de las
escuelas de decir la escuela africana
todavía no se dice subestación de si
preparar a los africanos para ser
realmente africanos occidente por
ejemplo o quiere los franceses son
franceses desde antes de la revolución
les han preparado ser polos de claro
digamos han acabado con las multi etnias
que había las 70 las 70 etnias que había
o grupos étnicos que habían francia
fueron hijos fueron digamos aniquilados
y justo le pido por favor que sea más
concreto con las respuestas porque el
tiempo es es poco y tenemos mucho tema
para analizar nicole pasemos al tema
de las repercusiones que puede traer
esto para la región y para el continente
africano ya lo decían después de ese
golpe de estado del mal y esto podría
comenzar un efecto de bola de nieve y
así lo vemos ya llevamos siete golpes de
estado dos de ellos frustrados pero
cinco muy concretados que más efectos
puede ejercer para el continente
africano y para esta región de áfrica
occidental
primero sería dentro del propio de los
propios países que ha habido esas
guerras las detenciones arbitrales
porque las sean que las personas que han
intentado levantar la voz para decir que
lo que estáis haciendo no es saben estas
personas serían seguramente
detenidas lalala y las mujeres serían
violadas porque cada vez que hay cual
perito de estrados hay guerras en áfrica
pues las que más pagan son las mujeres
habrá digamos violaciones masivas ahora
mismo y eso llevará a algunas personas
buscar una cuidada seguramente lo haga
dentro de áfrica primero porque siempre
la inmigración cuando pasas cosas así te
pasa de un país a otro dentro del pueblo
continente cuando ves que no hay
solución tratará a pasar a viajar hacia
europa pero es una pena todo eso porque
porque vuelvo a decir que es la
población que paga todas esas personas
que
impulsa golpe de estado siempre tendrá
siguen tenía tendrá el apoyo de otros
países occidente burger las personas que
pasa por golpe de estado a gobernar los
países africanos si suelen tener apoyo
también de los dirigentes europeos y es
una pena porque por qué no de las
muertes que suele haber cada vez que
pasa todo esas cuestiones de gol
pensador es una pena yo yo interior
dentro de mí porque sé que ahora mismo
que somos estamos hablando seguramente
hay mujeres que se están siendo violadas
pero hay varios varios organismos
internacionales entre ellos organismos
africanos que han impuesto sanciones a
estos gobiernos en golpistas han dejado
de lado a países como malí guinea y
níger en cierta forma también a sudan de
estos organismos continentales no tienen
derecho a participar en las reuniones y
también está en estudio imponer algunas
sanciones a nivel económico y esto
también viene desde países euro la unión
europea ha rechazado varios de estos de
estos golpes de estado entonces ahí
vemos que la comunidad internacional no
siempre avala estos gobiernos golpistas
que llegan al poder a imponer su
decisión en este caso es un escenario
diferente justo su opinión sobre las
repercusiones que puede traer esto para
la comunidad para el continente africano
para la construcción de esa democracia
la estabilidad política la estabilidad
del continente porque vemos otros países
en la región que también tienen
mandatarios que llevan varias décadas
gobernando se me ocurre en este momento
guinea ecuatorial por ejemplo que
podrían estar muy preocupados viendo
este tipo de acciones que están
ocurriendo en áfrica occidental
evidentemente cuando las barbas de tu
vecino veas cortar pon las tuyas a
remojar
es una costilla es una cuestión
evidentemente existe esa preocupación
muchos países africanos han convocado
una reunión para hablar y condenar esos
golpes de estado cuando ellos también
accedieron al poder a través de golpes
de estado
hay muchos organismos internacionales
que sancionan a esos países
golpistas cuando saben perfectamente que
hay empresas privadas que siguen
manteniendo relaciones con esos países
golpistas ahí ahí y digan los blogs las
compañías aéreas siguen volando al país
es decir
una cosa es el mensaje oficial de
condena al golpe de estado y otra cosa
es lo que realmente está pasando no se
rompen relaciones con esos países
evidentemente por qué razones habrá
quizá por por los recursos recursos
naturales que tiene el país no conviene
no les favorece a los países
occidentales romper totalmente las
relaciones
evidentemente el discurso oficial será
digamos sanciones de cualquier tipo
etcétera pero son sanciones medidas en
ese panorama justo entonces hablemos del
papel de francia ya lo mencionamos al
inicio varios de estos países fueron
colonia francesa mali burkina faso
guinea y níger y chad
hablemos qué papel tiene entonces el
gobierno francés allí que puede hacer
parís para ayudar en estas transiciones
de gobiernos o restablecer el orden
democrático y apoyar a los ciudadanos
qué papel puede jugar allí vamos a ver
francia tiene una única política para
áfrica suba este gobierne la derecha
gobierna la izquierda la política
francesa es la misma es decir hay que
hacer lo posible para que los países
africanos que han sido colonizados por
francia no se salgan del pack del
programa trazado por francia y con eso
quiero decir que cualquier país que
reivindica su absoluta soberanía ante
francia evidentemente es un país abocado
a la desestabilización
francia no puede no puede permitir que
su lengua deje de ser la lengua oficial
en esos países francia no puede permitir
que estos países sean totalmente
soberanos porque porque perdería muchas
muchas de las ventajas que tiene la
explotación de los recursos digamos
control de la moneda del país a través
del franco cf
etcétera
además además de eso controlar la
educación de esos países esta es una
cuestión
que están que está allí y además cuando
un presidente del civil se opone a las
decisiones de francia automáticamente es
digamos removido del poder se pierde el
poder e incluso francia detiene a un
presidente y de encarcelado sea
abiertamente entonces la población se
harta dice mira ya está bien eso somos
independientes o no lo somos claro pero
luego veo uno a países como por ejemplo
mal y que cuando tiene problemas con los
terroristas en el norte del país que es
una zona desértica hace parte del sahara
al primer país al que llama para pedir
ayuda militar es a francia justamente
entonces al b1 que no es una relación
solamente dependiente sino que es una
cooperación a todo nivel entre los dos
países y no siempre
la relación es este tire y afloje de
país colonial y país colonizado sino que
aquí hay unos compromisos unos acuerdos
y francia ha estado allí presente con
sus tropas en el saber para defender
precisamente hay tres países de estos
donde ha habido golpe de estado' en mali
burkina faso y chad que son están en la
región del sahel que están luchando
contra las insurgencias islámicas ellos
solos no lo han podido hacer
precisamente es una de las cuentas que
le han cobrado a los presidentes de
estos países que no han podido
garantizar la seguridad de los
ciudadanos y por eso ven con visto bueno
que los militares hayan tomado el poder
nicole para llamar mi pregunta entonces
como analizar entonces esta situación
con los grupos extremistas yihadistas
que están haciendo presencia allí en
esta franja que va por todo el sahel y
que logra llegar hasta somalia y cruzar
a la península arábica
si tiene muestra hable solamente de la
cantidad de militares franceses que hay
en áfrica yo creo que el papel que juega
yo no sé cómo lo ve la comunidad
internacional pero también los africanos
tiene
observan también las cosas son ellos que
viven día a día no la situación de los
milites militares franceses quizás
el mensaje que tiene la comunidad
internacional de
8.700 algo así militares que hay en
áfrica yo no sé si realmente juega un
papel para proyectos para proteger a la
nación al pueblo o para proteger a los
dirigentes ligados a y no a viejo en
entre comidas es verdad que con la
presidencia de todos esos militares que
hay en áfrica en los franceses los
gastos cascos azules
si realmente hacía un buen trabajo los
listas no iban aa
a machacar a áfrica como louis al
machacar una cosa es que haya presencia
de organismos internacionales en áfrica
y otra cosa es que el pueblo el cuerpo
pueblo africanos también tiene sus
militares no se puede anular a los
militares que conocen la cultura el país
el continente solamente porque hay que
traer la gente de fuera yo creo que todo
esto también nos tiene que mandar un
mensaje una reflexión que hacer qué es
lo que realmente está pasando porque
están irrumpiendo continuamente rebelde
y guisa machacando áfrica mientras que
hay una un grupo de militares
supuestamente
importante que tiene de otro continente
para proteger a sí claro nicole
justamente los militares ya lo estaba
mencionando yo en una de las
intervenciones de justo en la mayoría de
los casos son los que han tomado el
poder en estos países en estos siete
estados o cinco estados en donde triunfo
estos golpes de estado el caso de sudán
es muy particular porque los militares
tomaron el poder sacaron al presidente
transitorio que estaban encargados en un
balance de poder entre los militares y
este presidente de llevar el país hacia
unas elecciones libres las primeras en
tres décadas y los ciudadanos salieron a
las calles a rechazar esta forma de
actuar de los militares y pidieron
restablecer ese gobierno transitorio
para luego llevar la nación a unas
elecciones no en todos los casos según
esta experiencia en sudán los ciudadanos
están apoyando a los militares entonces
esto que lectura nos dice
yo creo que el mensaje que nos abre es
la lectura que hacemos de los militares
en áfrica es de violencia siempre es
verdad que las cosas cambian áfrica de
hace 20 años no es áfrica actualmente
ahora mismo la juventud tiene conciencia
y los propios militares también son
conscientes que son medios que tienen
que proteger a su pueblo y son
conscientes que no son gente de fuera
que van a venir a proteger a su gente y
están trabajando yo creo que es una
lectura que nos tiene que mandar una
reflexión ahora mismo que el programa el
propio africano puede tomar la
decisión de sea un militar o un bandido
si tiene que luchar para sus pueblos
para su gente yo creo que es una lectura
bien claro el gracia occidente tiene que
reflexionar para ver realmente es
necesario mandar tantos militares como
está mandando en áfrica yo creo que no
la respuesta para mí es lo
que me quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa y quiero
y comenzar con las conclusiones y para
ello me parece importante ver cómo
evitar estos escenarios de golpes estas
irrupciones
arbitrarias del poder de los militares
en estos países sea cual sea el
escenario pero sin duda alguna esto
afecta a los procesos democráticos y
afecta a la institucionalidad de estos
países cómo se pueden evitar y cómo
garantizar que los ciudadanos van a
poder participar en procesos limpios
elegir a sus ciudadanos a sus candidatos
y que éstos puedan completar sus tiempos
para los que fueron designados en el
poder comienzo con justo
sí cómo evitar lo
habría habría que cambiar el mensaje de
los instructores militares extranjeros
que son los encargados muchas veces de
formar a los cuadros militares africanos
habría que hacerles ver que los
militares deben se les debe enseñar a
hacer abstracción de su fuerza de su
poder militar para permitir el
desarrollo político habría que
enseñarles eso y habría que formar a la
población africana la población civil
tanto en la iglesia como en las escuelas
como en los medios de comunicación al no
tolerar
cualquier tipo de gobierno que se quiera
hacer con el poder de forma permanente o
vitalicia entonces si se forma la
población para que no toleren entonces
si podrán reaccionar si se forman los
militares a los militares para que hagan
abstracción y que vean que su papel es
solo de defender el territorio y no de
agredir a la población entonces sí
podrán digamos dejar que los srs en los
poderes civiles
pues convoca en sus elecciones y los
hilos y los hilos y los gobernantes no
podrán solicitar del concurso de los
militares para machacar violentar a la
población justo creo que eso en sintonía
con el golpe de septiembre del 2021 en
guinea donde un oficial de alto rango
que había sido entrenado por estados
unidos derrocó a un presidente que
estaba intentando aferrarse al poder
allí en esta nación vamos en sintonía
con lo que usted menciona nicole su
opinión que hacer para evitar este tipo
de escenarios políticos de irrupción de
militares en el poder
yo creo que las condenas internacionales
tiene que ser condenas reales no tanto
las condenas de áfrica cedeao el guiño
de las africanas van africanizar tiene
que ser condenas reales que no puedes
seguir la unidad con todo lo que está
pasando da igual golpe editado violencia
paga de derechos humanos tiene que haber
de verdad hay como un control que el
proceso de la paz esté en las manos de
los propios africanos yo creo que
también es muy importante no podemos ser
los eternos alumnos de occidente yo creo
que tiene que ser los procesos que los
propios africanos tienen que diseñar
este modelo de un proceso también
tenemos que acabar con lo que es
los presidentes ancianos que se eterniza
en el poder yo no salí de ahí dicen que
realice el que haber siempre golpe de
estado y la gimnasia porque si no son
los presidentes ancianos son sus hijos
se les sigue en el poder yo creo que son
modelos de las cosas que tenemos que ir
cambiando para poder construir una
con un modelo propio africano y
alternancia en el poder que es básico en
los procesos democráticos me queda un
minuto de programa por favor las
conclusiones que creen ustedes que va a
suceder con estos países serán
reconocidos estos gobiernos habrá
elecciones ocurrirán otros golpes de
estado en otros países rápidamente y muy
puntual justo por favor si ocurrirán
otros otros golpes en otros países uno y
esos países con el tiempo serán
reconocidos serán reconocidos porque
porque es necesario que sean reconocidos
para que los pues los países
occidentales sigan exportando los
recursos y sigan sacando no sean
buscando salida al mercado
armamentista claro ni con su opinión
para el cierre
el compacto porque finalmente esos
países van a ser reconocidos porque como
hay el recursos minerales hay bastantes
recursos que interesa a occidente
terminará reconociendo a esos dirigentes
para tener un amigo pues les agradezco
muchísimo que hayan estado con nosotros
aquí en el debate de france 24 habernos
puesto en contexto en la situación de
estos países africanos una realidad muy
distante para américa latina pero que
sin duda alguna es interesante ver aquí
en desglose a ustedes muchas gracias por
habernos acompañado gracias por la
sintonía y continúen dejando sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]